this time I'm on the trail of a giant
hippopotamus
when it comes to land mammals it's one
of the largest weighing up to 6,000
pounds on this adventure my plan is to
get within arm's reach of these
formidable gladiators Baelfire and
they're not happy if the secrets of
hippo sweater unlocked some scientists
believe it could result in powerful new
antibiotics and sun blocks for humans
but no one's ever retrieves wet from a
live under ugh wild hippo I'm gonna give
it a try but I can't just stroll up to
one and ask for a sample one thing is
clear I need an innovative approach to
get close
and I think I have just the idea
a hippo hideout Wow but I like this size
I'm building a new suit to approach wild
hippos so I can get near enough to
scrape the sweat off their skin which I
will use this extendable pole with a
scraper on the end the one thing I do
know it will not be easy
Smithsonian taxidermist Paul rhymer
helps us brainstorm the perfect design
wider than that my guess is if the
overall body is a little shorter and L
and a little you know shorter this way a
little less long and you're going to
appear like a smaller less threatening
him again we decide to model the suit
after a small female compare which could
attract male hippos and increase my
chances of getting a sweat sample we'll
also give my disguise a submissive head
posture to discourage a territorial
charge from a dominant bull alright
construction of my hippo disguise moves
full steam ahead this is the belly and
again this is the front leg that's great
so now this will be painted it's gonna
be amazing it doesn't look great my
protective hippo structure is finally
finished this is what's gonna keep me
safe and sound in the wilds of Africa
now I just need to determine whether it
really will keep me as safe as I've been
told
the moment of truth has arrived
it's taken over 500 man-hours to design
a bill this state-of-the-art hippo
disguise is as tough as a tank it
features a life-sized fiberglass head
cast from a real hippopotamus set in a
submissive posture to decrease the
probability of a violent attack
grade three Kevlar body armor to
safeguard against assault from heavy
artillery like tusks and teeth four
hidden cameras fixed on every side for
360 degree surveillance specialized
removable back plan for cross
ventilation and extreme temperatures
patches on left and right flanks
strategically placed for deployment of
scientific instruments
operation hippo stakeout it's ready for
deployment our strategy is to carry the
hippo suit close to the water and leave
me alone inside right here
I'm gonna get me inside this head and
approach them and we'll walk maybe
there's a giant hippo near shore I just
need to get close enough to open my
hatch and extend the scraper but as I
move in he lets me know I am not welcome
on his turf like my decoy hippo bodies
are strong and sturdy to endure assaults
but hauling that massive body must be
exhausting
atleast hippos can take a dip for relief
I've got to tough it out on land it's
pretty nerve-wracking just sitting
inside this thing and not knowing what's
gonna happen you know you really I have
to rely on my video monitor to even know
what's going on outside it's just scary
it's just scary the stench is just
overpowering in here since I covered
this with hippo don't it's baking in the
Sun and it just it's overpowering its
eye watering bad house
I think the body's definitely helped uh
the believability factor of my hippo
decoy
the first time I deploy it with mud on
it man I had a boat come so close my
decoy definitely holds promise is a
stationary blind my spirits have been
read
I made my disguise look and smell more
like the real deal and it paid off with
a close encounter
you